but why was he seeking God God if is the
love it is a the question of the
humanity the his music transports a
message a measured she is an a not a
kind of language a a special kind of
language he expresses she express
thoughts and emotions and I am of the
opinion that distance parts of of
message the message our emotion
emotional they are social as a political
and they are also ethics and ethics
let's get back to that in a second Luis
listen in this quote of Bruno Walter
good Walter specifically says that this
God Marla was seeking for he had he who
had disappeared from the cosmos might
perhaps reappear in the cell now you are
cell biology yes I heard that about the
music being the first bit of DNA of
course DNA hadn't been discovered when
he was alive but that's another story
altogether
what worries me is your introduction Dom
said we're going to have a metaphysical
discussion excuse me I'm a scientist
metaphysic metaphysics is junk and
because Marla was a bit metaphysical
doesn't mean to say we must collude with
him that's what I like to hear
strong support so I think that there's a
great danger in taking a metaphysical
view and trying to interpret his music
in metaphysical terms in fact I'm deeply
vicious of all those interpretations of
music which do not involve unit are not
talking about Vargas operas or things
like that where there's a libretto but
where there's just music to try and
interpret it in verbal terms I think is
suspicious and suspect beyond region and
his mice might be a very nice
intellectual conversation but
intellectually is empty I would like in
a friendly way to answer metaphysics is
junk okay but then I look then they told
me we have you know real science who
deal with real problems only should I go
to most fundamental science quantum
physics and I know hahaha
yeah one claim universe cash limit
doesn't kept infinite in time there is a
big bang there wasn't a big bang sorry
with lovers we're never s grazie as
quantum physicists are in this sense
point to now just don't tell me they are
not serious because at the same time I
know it is a very serious quantum
physics is serious as you can get 1000%
experimentally confirmed and you cannot
say what does it mean what kind of
reality but that's another problem first
I want aggressively to answer to this
point about what mother would have said
nothing probably something totally
stupid why there is an excellent Jewish
story in Talmud a friend told me about
it where two rabbis debate a point then
the one who is losing the argument said
let's call God that's what God let's
call God Allah conquer you know like in
any Hall
Woody Allen the Canadian gamer and
McLuhan comes no God comes and then the
other guy says to God will stupid old
man you created the world but it's as we
all can see a catastrophic stupid world
you did your job
bit off and leave us why spell Moody's
to debate serious questions and that's
the greatness of drew
- gorgeous oh my god they're right and
run away I will constrict I would have
been threatening mother the same way but
now a more serious question now I'm not
no no no I don't mean this in a cynical
way I claim the truck to make a serious
message the true greatness of truly
great artists is my god in their work
there they put much more than they knew
in their prostate Wagner he did set all
possible vulgar anti-semitism but they
can Elementary look at Wagner's work
watch the center of an Aryan hero figure
of wandering jew my god everything
changes immediately you see it small but
now more serious we had a certain
reading here which was dead malar went
through that touch they put it a zero
point of absolute void and so the end of
the world and saw the end shadi saw the
Holocaust to cut it short
well now if you allow me just to
terminus to make this point with all ger
agressivity listening precisely to this
last movement now of the fifth symphony
I claim if there is a thing that Muller
emphatically didn't see it was this
because you know okay we know how
history of music goes very vaguely first
we have pre-modern music where you have
all those references to the Harmonia
Mundi all those referring then back is
the first radical moderniser
he saw no harmony in the world you have
to invent impulse rational order unto
music then romanticism where you have
this struggle with material with
romanticism that's how I read it very
naively you cannot do it like modular
beautiful melodies there you were you
must struggle for a long time so that
the mule the melody must arise through
this density but that's not the end I
claim what happens with chamber and
afterwards it's something
more terrifying it's really like moving
from classical physics with dense matter
to some more quantum space where you see
that like you know you have sometimes
the feeling when I am listening to
Sundberg and my favorite åberg of course
you know this nice science-fiction topic
where do you think you are reality in
reality but then somebody tells you but
we already live in artificial reality
and then in one of the much better than
made matrix the 13th floor you have the
scene where the guy goes to the end of
the world and his reality dissolving
instead of matter you get rust
geometrical lines I claim that in
modernism radical modernism from
Schoenberg onwards the very material is
dissolving in this way that's the true
modernism this is what you which is why
I claim if we already talk with this
elementary parallels not definitely not
malar what he is doing in this last
movement this is the traditional
vitalist strategy of you know yeah yeah
I'm ready to lose it all but then it it
returns in triumph and so on and so on
the true color form is for example my
favorite Rain Bird gray leader why it's
unique because in one same piece you
pass from this late romantic passionate
condensed movement universe to this
abstract universe and I must interrupt
you there is no relationship between art
and science and so I didn't say did I
say well your sounds like you're
speaking about there is a relationship
between music and physics and there
isn't now all I have ever very here is
more precise what I am NOT gonna saying
is the following probably you will not
accept it I no problem ok but ok look
let's leave this debate for later ok
because you know I'm deeply sympathetic
of science in the sense that I don't buy
this [ __ ] science is abstract
alienating I think that scientific
disenchantment of the world is the best
thing that kept
to humanity I think that we should push
it to the end and when we are talking
about crisis of values don't forget that
all horrible political systems always
Nazism fascism Stalinism they all
perceived themselves as fighting
nihilism and return to some kind of
values so I think you personal passed a
point but one can not deny that is a
metaphysical question which one we have
metaphysical question it is a effect and
on one can't say we cannot say that the
composes was was were not intelligent
persons no they all do but then they
must put into into into he healthy we
have thought he had not written all only
nodes oh ok ok
I heard today he was just as you said an
eclectic amateur or a Lebanese
philosophy goatee slime no no no neat
huh stop for a moment okay ah there's
one thing that many things to say but
when we try to understand the Maillard
situation he laughed
Nietzsche and he laughed the Gospels he
it's a very uneasy situation I think he
was not happy with the notion of the
ubermensch Calamari's said the
ubermensch was meant by Nietzsche as
this next stage of human development we
know there will never be a next stage of
the human development right and you in
America when you like someone you say
he's a man you don't say he's an uber
man ah so it tells us something about
about this to the absurdity of the
notion of the environment we many of us
listen to the Ninth Symphony
yesterday night which ends the last
movement is all about silence
this is someone it tells us something
about the the mentality the religiosity
of mother so you can say some in every
major religion you have the tension
between the Gnosticism and the non
Gnosticism in in Judaism Christianity
and Islam the Gnostic says I believe I
know the non Gnostic says I know I
believe it's a huge difference and this
major bullet religions I bill are built
on this notion and by ending this great
symphony with silence mother says I'm
not a gnostic I don't know I am
searching I like the type of the
conference the Questor because indeed
that's a quest it is a religious quest I
see elements of a religious quest in it
but it's not a gnostic arrogance
mother's not saying I know I know about
God I know but no no Jesus I'm looking
for I'm on a quest